Come here. Here we go.
Hello for Amy.
Okay, so so I just got back. I just got back from...
...The Book of Henry. So this movie was...
It was bad. It was bad. It was--no, it wasn't okay
It was--oh, I don't--I don't know where to start.
I don't--I do not know where to start with this one because it was just--it was...
It...it...
So the first half of the movie is just like insufferably twee,
while the second half...is, is...
Mind-blowing in, in just how like...
just, just how
how absurd it is and just just
it's it's it's
flabbergasting when you start watching the character to go through these actions
that there is is no
like
sensible
grounding element for and this so it in
In a weird way this movie almost
almost plays like a
PG -- what was this rated?
PG-13
Okay
so this almost plays like a PG-13 version of
Burn after Reading
In the--to a degree, to a degree, this is this is about stupid people making
insane decisions for ludicrous reasons and
and
You, you kind of want it to just be like a dark comedy, but it's, it's played
Just absolutely straight
Just like just super serious like the whole time and so, so the first half of the movie is, is...
Unbearably twee so it's about, it's about this kid named Henry, and now Henry is
naturally just a like a mega super genius, like not just good at something like good at...
everything. So the opening scene of the movie after the credits is...
Like kids doing, doing like you know just, just a front of class essay
presentation where they've got to, they have to talk about "My Legacy"...
And so the first kid is talking about how he wants to be an Olympic Dodgeball champion...
And now these kids are all like eleven,
so it's like...
That's actually really hard to read at start, like I thought they were a little bit younger because it starts off with this kid,
you know talking about being an Olympic Dodgeball champion and eleven is like...
maybe a little old for that, but it's still, it's not really out of the realm, of the realm of reality, like kids,
kids want, you know, I don't know how the world works, whatever.
So next up.
Next up is Henry, and Henry gets up and is basically...
Like French Philosopher. He's like Baudrillard, he just gets up and like...(pretends to smoke a cigarette)
(with faux French accent) "Life is meaningless.
We are all but dust."
No, more or less, like he stands up and and talks about how
like, life is fleeting
and we don't know, we don't know what's coming and, like. really the, the like true meaning of life is to leave a legacy of
of kindness and goodness behind us and...
But it's, the whole thing is presented in a really like
cynical tone of voice and he explicitly calls out the first kid about how like
"Yeah, man, like you don't even, like look at you. You don't even know that that dodgeball isn't an Olympic sport."
So he basically says it's like,
"Yeah, you know..." like the whole thing is really like,
"I'm so much smarter than everyone else in the class
because I'm, I'm so much more grown up and mature than all of you who want, who want dumb things like to be Olympic Dodgeball champions."
Come on, Amy. Arrr.
Arr--hey, hey, no biting, no biting.
No biting, okay?
I need my notes, and by notes, I mean the tweets that I wrote while I was in the movie because there was like
four other people.
So that's the note that the movie begins on is this this like class presentation where Henry just like
schools the rest of the kids about how like dumb their dreams are, but then on the way
it was like, of course, like bell rings and...
Everybody's going, everybody's filtering out, and the teacher pulls Henry aside, and is like, "Remind me again
why we can't put you in an advanced school?"
And he spouts off just like the most pre-canned...You know...
intellectual response about how, about how he...
"Socializing with an equivalent peer group is...
Good for my, my...
Moral and social development." And like so on and so forth and it's one of the things is like technically true
maybe I guess sort of, but like he clearly doesn't believe it, so...
And, and everything that comes after like, this kid has so much control
Over every aspect of his life because the next 20 minutes after this are essentially setting up that like he runs the house
You know it's like, Mom, Mom is basically a functioning alcoholic and she's really...
like not
clued into the, the world that she lives in, and Henry handles all the finances and Henry handles all of the like
household needs and Henry handles like
everything while she works her waitress job that Henry keeps telling her, like they keep dropping through this
through the like first half of the movie like, "You don't need to go to work anymore, Mom.
I told you, like you can take some time off.
You don't need to work anymore, Mom." Because she works his waitress job and just like a tiny little diner and...
Right so she gets drunk with her co-workers, she plays video games
Henry's always like, "We need to do, I need to show you the finances," and she's like "Whatever..." you know
"Haha computers,"--there's a bunch of gags about how she doesn't know how to use a computer and...
then it...
then two, two threads
start being introduced alongside each other, the first is that Henry has headaches,
and the second is that, Rear Window style, he sees his neighbor
what he sus--he suspects--he starts to suspect the neighbor is...
the neighbor dude is abusing his daughter, is like, is
sexually abusing his daughter,
his stepdaughter, so...
Daughter is...
Henry's age and yeah, he sees
suspicious activity and then...
then (he chuckles)
then it just kind of like accelerates
super rapidly to the point that like, you know he sees her on the bus and...
They don't--they say she has bruises, but I didn't, you don't see any...
bruises, like so she's just got her hair like you know kind of covering one side of her face
Which you know, I mean, fair enough, but they they don't, like there's no moment where she like brushes it aside
And you kinda get a glimpse like oh, she's got a black eye, like oh, stuff's going down.
So Henry, just like sits there in class like getting angrier and angrier and then he gets up in the middle of class,
barges into the principal's office,
and starts yelling at her about how he's filed so many reports about this,
and they're not doing anything and why isn't anyone taking him seriously?
And it happened so fast and it's, it's like, wait. This is, this is, there are predicate conversations here?
You've already brought this up? Like...
what? This is, it's a lot of information that kind of comes out of nowhere, so it's apparently this thing that Henry's been like...
thinking about for a while, and he tries calling...
Child Protective Services, but it turns out that, that stepdad's
brother is like the head of CPS and...
so immediately Henry starts
scribbling all of these notes in this red notebook, and he starts like going around town and I...
There's this one moment where he's like on a bridge.
He's on this like big causeway bridge, and he like looks off one side
And he goes looks off the other and takes out his tape recorder is like you know,
"Four hundred foot drop on...
on the south side, very deep water on the north."
Puts it away. I'm like, "Is this is this kid planning, planning to hide a body?
What's, what's going on here?" and then he goes into a
gun store...
and like hides behind a gun rack as he listens to a -- and makes notes as he listens to a dude
try to buy a gun
without registration and hears the guy say, "So, oh what if, what if Dominique sent me?" and...
yeah, okay, so he takes all of these notes and...
Whatever, then his headaches get, get worse and he dies.
(chuckles slightly)
About halfway through the movie. So the first half of the movie is is basically...
a whole bunch of twee crap at home that builds up to nothing.
Henry like...
making all of these weird notes, and then he gets sick and dies, and it's so...
Predictable, like the way that the character is written is so predictable that he got into the hospital. So he goes to the hospital and
he wakes up after surgery and...
I'm like, I'm amazed that they haven't
had a scene
where Henry explains his own illness to a doctor and as I as I am composing a tweet
making that joke,
Henry starts explaining his own disease to a doctor and to, to the surgeon and now surgeon McHotty
Doctor, Doctor McHotterson is...
Kind of important, okay, so Henry's in the hospital for a bit, and there's more scenes where
Henry like tells Mom like. "No you got to, you got to pay attention to the finances like this is really important."
And he's like trying to tell her about like stocks and like which stocks she needs to watch and like,
"The textiles, you got to pay closer attention to the textiles, the energy stocks are largely tied up in like
subsidiary bonds," and so--and she's none of it because her kid's dying and
then Henry dies and, and he just kind of...
Vanishes like there's no...
There's no funeral. There's no funeral scene. Henry just dies.
I mentioned there's no funeral scene because it's, it's going to be important later, but so Henry dies and
the second half of the movie just goes so far off the rails
as Henry's younger brother Peter...
Sees the red notebook and now Henry had told Peter, "You got to make sure Mom reads the notebook, but only Mom, not you."
So Peter takes the notebook and is like,
"Mom, you've got to read this, you got to read this." He flips through it a little bit, and I guess kind of gets the...
gets the image, and it's like...
Step-by-step instructions on murdering Glen, the, the neighbor.
Like, and, and there's a whole scene where they have an entire back-and-forth conversation like so Mom,
Peter, and the book have an entire back-and-forth conversation where like...
You know Mom will raise an objection, and then they'll flip to a section in the book that is like, you know
It's like, "There has to be something else that we can do!"
Flip open the book, "Why there's nothing else you can do," and...
It goes on like that and then the movie stays in that mode for like...
Most of the rest of it, pretty much like the rest of the runtime stays in that mode where Mom like
gets convinced that she needs to do this thing, she needs to follow Henry's instructions and murder Glen.
So...
He leaves this cache of like cassette tapes, and she's gotten a Walkman
so she's walking around with a Walkman and earbuds in,
having these conversations with the tape like it's, it's that,
that gag where a character is listening to something that's
pre-recorded--they already did this with the book, you may notice, but so someone's listening to something pre-recorded and
They keep-- it's like, "This is insane." "I know you think that's insane."
You know, that they, they ask hypothetical--they ask questions out loud or express distrust
Or just do things and the tape recorder like syncs up with it perfectly
And it's like they don't just do that...So they already did it with the book then they do it again with the tape recorder
over and over and over and over again for like a solid half-hour
And it's down to things like
Henry via tape recorder walks Mom through...
buying a sniper rifle with a suppressor and a night-vision scope and...
Oh dang it. One kind -- like soft head ammunition that's going to like explode, like shatter, once it...
Once it, it hits a target so it's going to be like almost
impossible to trace and..
And she does it! She does these things. Like the tape recorder tells her what to say,
including name-dropping Dominique in order to like buy this gun off-the-books. Oh by the way she also
discovers that she had like six hundred thousand dollars in cash in a checking account and...
Untold amounts worth of investments because...
Because Henry is, is...
Perfect and amazing and has made them quite wealthy
You know like, actually before she buys the gun like Henry
The, the tapes walk her through like, "Alright you gotta go--" It's like, "Okay. Go up to the ATM and withdraw
$500 and then if you get to another ATM within 20 minutes,
you can withdraw more money," like basically if you can hit three ATMs within 20 minutes, then you won't hit the daily withdrawal limit.
Okay, well this is--she's, she's rich. Like she has six hundred thousand dollars in a checking account.
She can just go into a bank and take out five grand and the teller--like that's not suspicious
behavior, if you have six hundred thousand dollars in cash,
withdrawing a, like big chunk of like...
That's not suspicious. It's not suspicious when you're rich.
Anyway, anyway, so she buys this gun, she buys this
sniper rifle, and goes out and starts practicing with it, guided of course by the tapes every step of the way and...
Henry has already like bought her a new car that he has stashed in a parking lot
On like the other side of town so that she just needs to go pick it up
and it's going to make a better getaway vehicle because no one in the neighborhood will recognize it because it's not her,
it's not the car that she normally drives and...
and...
Oh my God, so there's a scene where she goes to confront Glen.
So this is after Henry's death/
This is, this is right around the time that she's really like convinced herself that she's going to go through with it...
and...
so she goes, she goes to Glen house--Glen's house and
The, the, the girl is on the stairs.
She, she asks the girl. I don't, I don't remember her name. She's not, she's not a character. She's barely a plot device.
She's, she's barely present in the movie so like whatever but...
She's having this non-conversation. She's like. "Oh, how are things going?"
"Okay," and and Mom's like, "It'll get easier...
soon."
Wink. Like she doesn't actually wink, but it's like it's so...
Like the line delivery is so loaded. "It'll get easier.
Soon." Oh, oh, I need to talk timeline, okay. So one of the things is established early in the movie
is that the, there is a...
Talent show next week.
When Mom has this conversation, it's the day before
the talent show. So all of this from...so Henry has gotten sick,
died, and Mom has
become a
hardened killer
who is comfortable with a sniper rifle in the span of a week
or less than. Because this is now the night before like, so the pretense for going over is like,
"I need you to sign some papers."
But she's using the papers, so it's just a like you know parental release form like,
"Hey, I'm taking--" because she's gonna bring Daughter over to, she's gonna bring her to the talent show because Glen's gonna stay home because he's not
big on going to that kind of stuff like whatever.
And...but she then uses the signature to like...
forge...
custody papers,
giving her custody of the girl in the event of..
But like and she's of course got the tape recorder playing,
and Henry's walking her through it and is like,
I back dated them a year,
using a signature lifted from this other neighbor who died like six months ago," and it's like...
okay, so...
Talent show comes up...
And Mom is like a chaperone there like standing by the door,
you know so that she's got an alibi, and then it's like once everything starts she like puts in the tape recorder
and it's like, Henry is like "Alright, on my, on my three. One, two, three."
Hits the watch.
45 minutes. Gotta go. Jump to the car, starts driving.
and it's like intercutting. Mom going and getting her like death trap set up,
with with the talent show, and...
I was going, right at the moment that I was going to make a gag about the
about a like really bad reference to the...
Baptism scene in Godfather where it's cutting between
Michael's son being baptized and Michael's goons...
Assassinating, assassinating some of the other the other crime families in the, in the city.
Right at the time that I was going to make that comparison,
Mom's like getting the gun set up and like adjusting the scope and and back at the talent show,
a girl starts singing
Amazing Grace.
So it's intercutting, you know...
(gun cocking noises)
(imitating a girl singing) "Who saved a wretch--" (more gun noises) "--like me..."
Okay, so she lures Glen out into the woods...
It involves...
mechanisms that make no sense whatsoever.
She lures Glen out into the woods and is like lining up this, the shot.
And she's got the headphones on.
And...There's this big Rube Boldberg contraption -- oh that's another thing's that Henry also builds Rube Goldberg machines...
And...it's, it starts like she accidentally bumps it and it's set up as a joke because it's like,
"Oh, you...
Eliminate all distractions." And right then she like slips and hits it and starts going and of course it's making all this noise
she's like lining up the shot and then....
It ends and like this thing flips down it's all these Polaroids of like her kids
and then she has this moment like she's ready to shoot this guy in the head--
oh, there was a line, right. When she's practicing the scene, when it goes into the scene where she's practicing with the gun,
there's the line
"Alright, Mom, so plywood is only slightly thicker than the human skull,"
And...But so anyway, so she looks at all these pictures of her kids, and then she has this moment
of realization that she's listening to a tape recorder of her dead son--
of her dead eleven-year-old son like
telling her how to murder this guy
she's like, "You're just a kid,"
And...so she like walks out of the kids' little clubhouse and Glen has like come up,
it was like, What the hell's going on?" And she--cause she's standing there with this giant gun you know...
And she just puts it down and is like, "I know
what you did. I know what you're doing. I'm gonna ruin you. I'm gonna--" you know they have this confrontation...
And...he calls, he calls the cops on--He's like actually the police commissioner. So he calls like the sheriff on her...
And...goes, goes back home,
and she jumps in the car and like, to get back to the school on time to cover her alibi...
And...
Oh.
Backing up a little bit, when they get to the talent show,
Doctor McHotty shows up...
Because Peter invited him.
He shows up
because the younger brother of his dead patient
invited him.
Yeah, okay, so she...
She gets back and that's intercutting
with
Glen back at home as Glen kind of realizes...
It is like his little house of cards is like crumbling around him and the police all show up like this...
The framing of it is really weird because like he called...
His own people to come get her so they come up to his house, but it's framed as though
they're coming to get
him, which is sort of the intentional
implications that he feels like you know, this is all collapsing because he gets a phone call from his brother
who's like, "We're going to have to open an investigation," and then he shoots himself?
And yeah, so back at the talent show she gets there kind of just in time as...
as...as Peter is doing...
his act, is doing, is doing his talent act and his talent act is...
He's got a chest. It's like, "I'm going...
to make my brother
reappear, and when I'm done he will be in the midst of all of us."
And then he does the thing, opens the chest, nothing happens.
"Henry, where are you? Henry, where are you?" Kicks it.
And it starts...
spewing out...
Snowflakes.
Like fake snow, fake snow that it sprays all over the auditorium and starts raining down...
Wafting down, covers, covers everyone, these snowflakes and the audience...
Stands up and and just like standing ovation applause. And I'm like, "Is...?"
The visual implication is that he has scattered...
Henry's ashes over the crowd.
(whisper-yelling) He scatters Henry's ashes over the crowd!
So...
(jostles camera)
immediately after, immediately after
the talent show like they step outside and the police are there and they're like, "Oh stepdad shot, Glen shot himself," so like...
you know Child Protective Services wants to talk to her now.
And it just kind of like quickly montages through like the outside of the courthouse, you hear voiceover be like, "We award custody to, to...
you know
so-and-so..."
and it's like instant, like just, just...
So she she just gets folded
right into the family taking, Henry's place and...
the final emotional beat, the...
I don't even know. I have...okay, okay...
I honestly don't know if I want to spoil this for people because if you're going to see this,
the, the final emotional beat of this movie is...
so...
amazing as a cherry on top
of just an awful movie that I don't wanna spoil, so if you, if--if you intend on seeing this, like I've spoiled...
90% of the movie and I've missed a lot of the good stuff...I have missed a lot of the like just...
"Oh man" moments, but this last one I'm going to leave for you, so skip ahead
if, if you don't, if, if you do plan on seeing it like, that,
that is one thing that I want, I want you to...
I want you to know that something is coming, but I don't want you to know what it is. So skip ahead...
if you're in that camp otherwise, okay, so...
There's, there's this leitmotif
throughout the movie where, so Peter and
Henry sleep in the same room.
You know they've got, they've got beds in the same room.
And every time it's time for bed, Mom like stands at the door,
and there's like this little dinosaur nightlight.
She's like, "On or off?" And it's always like Peter says "On,"
Henry says "Off." And then there's the door, "Open or closed?" Peter says,
"Open," Henry says, "Closed."
And...it's like that every time but then she like alternates, so like the first time she turns on the dinosaur
but closes the door and then the next time she leaves the dinosaur off, but leaves the door open.
And...Then the final moment, so there's this whole scene where...
Oh. It's even more perfect, alright. There's also an earlier scene where Mom...
calls Henry "Enchilada Number One" as she tucks him in and calls Peter "Enchilada Number Two" at, when she
tucks him in and then there's a conversation between them where
Peter's like, "Why, why is he enchilada number one?" and she's like, "Well because he's older.
He, he got here first." And s'like whatever, but so there's this whole conversation as, you know, so
the girl, so Peter is now sleeping in Henry's bed, and the girl is sleeping in Peter's old bed, and
she tucks them in and calls
Peter "Enchilada Number One"...
And...the girl...
"Butterfly Number One"?
And goes over to the door and
holds up the dinosaur, and is like "On or off?" And they both say, "On."
"Open or closed?" And they both say "Closed." And then the door closes and the credits roll.
The final emotional beat of this movie is, is that she has just like
slotted perfectly into...
this family...
because, because...
Henry's...
spirit or legacy or essence...
like has, has
infected them? Or has like just, just...
like it's all about, it's, it's, it's trying to be about like, okay the impact of
people in other people's lives but...
it...
It makes Henry out to be like a poltergeist, a like haunting spirit
who like possesses people and
overrides their free will and they're, and by calling her a butterfly,
there's, there's this implication
that like in her
Henry has been reborn.
So...
So go see this movie, so go see it, you, you owe it, you owe it to yourself to...
bear witness...
It's...
It's been a while since I've seen anything remotely like it and so I won't, I am not,
I am not going to be surprised at all if like
Kathleen Kennedy is having some, some very serious discussions about the future of Star Wars
after this weekend because Colin Trevorrow is
currently slated to direct
Episode Nine, and I get the feeling that that might change after this.
This is bad, like okay, so Colin Trevorrow's...
his first movie to get any real, any real notice was Safety Not Guaranteed, which I thought was okay.
It wasn't, it, it wasn't...
Really that special, like, so it came out in you know, kind of the, the New Indie wave,
the, the Indie Rock wave in, in
the late aughts, mid-late aughts, and
you know it it was
not as good as I Heart Huckabees or
Juno, but it was okay and
Jurassic World was just a mess and now this, this is...
this is astonishing in just how like...
The, the failure to balance tone or even just like step back and ask like, "Is this a good decision?
Should-- is this what we want to do? Is this what we're doing right now?"
It's, it's amazing.
(squeaking) It's amazing.
Aso the movie feels,
the movie feels really dated in a lot of ways, like it very much feels like it, it belongs in the
stable of Wes Anderson miitators, but...
It's not good.
Like it's not a good Wes anderson imitation.
And it's not an actual Wes Anderson imitation, it just kind of, it
has that same kind of sense and sensibility, like it has that very manic pixie dream girl sort of twee you know?
Saccharine...
cute...
tone about it, so like you know it's like oh mom plays video games, and she, she gets drunk with her friend,
but it's just kind of wacky and, but it's bad, but it's wacky, but it's bad, but it's wacky and
she plays ukulele with the kids and she's really like she's not really mom
she's like the kids best friend, but the movie can't quite decide if that's a bad--
like if she's a bad mom or if she's a good mom
like if she's actually like...
If she's actually negligent which she kind of is or if she's like..."oh know, like you're a great mom. You've been in--"
There's there's an entire conversation when, when Henry's dying where she's like,
"I never learned how to be a mother," and Henry tells her, "I never taught you how to do that."
Okay, so...
so yeah.
It's, it's a mash-up of every precocious,
every precocious kid movie from like the late 80s through the mid aughts.
smashed together, you know, there's...
What do we got, where is my list? Little Man Tate? I know was one of them. Radio Flyer.
Like I mean because like yeah, so Radio Flyer.
Definitely. Little Man Tate. Where's my list? Where's my list?
Pay it Forward meets Rear Window meets just the kid from Jerry Maguire.
Oh, there's another scene, another thing is that so like Henry is this total, I don't get why anybody likes him, so...
He's, he's not only like smarter than the rest of his peers by...
You know, a mile,
he's, he's really self-righteous about it, like he's super smug about it and the movie opens with him being like an obnoxious
dick right in front of the class.
But we're told repeatedly that like everyone loves Henry and everyone wants to be his friend.
Despite the fact that he's like an antisocial prick.
You know everything that we've seen is that this kid is a buzzkill.
He like hates everything. He's exactly the kind of kid who you just know that if he didn't get brain cancer and die that...
He's the kid who's gonna like spent his teenage years being like, "Oh,
pop music is like the worst. I listen to Led Zeppelin."
You know, you just know that's who he's gonna be like, he is exactly that asshole.
And, but everyone apparently likes him like he doesn't he doesn't get the crap beaten out of her every day for being you know, smug, and.
But even then like when we're told everybody likes him, we're just kind of told that everybody likes him,
because we don't really meet any other characters.
So?
Like?
There's one other kid in his class that you kind of meet aside...
So there's Girl and then Dumb Kid and so there's Dumb Kid from the beginning and then you learn like no one else,
they don't even have any other kids in the class like,
have a one-off line about like, "Is Henry gonna be okay?" like
there's--Dumb Kid has speaking parts. No one else has speaking parts.
The moment Henry dies,
Peter immediately like is possessed by his spirit.
And is suddenly like pep-talking Mom and like teaching her how to be a real mom, and it becomes a mechanical genius overnight.
This we will, we will be hearing, we will be hearing from this again.
Absolutely go.
Go experience this. Don't worry about giving your money to an awful film.
It won't make a difference. This is going to bomb. No one is going to go see this. This is it, just yeah, so...
Enjoy sitting in an empty theater and watching a incomprehensibly...
Poorly considered movie. And, and just it's, it's Winter's Tale cubed like...
Yeah, yeah.